[Music]
the billions of rats in India a group
appropriately referred to as pores or
mischiefs
may seem unstoppable to humans as they
help themselves to vast amounts of grain
the average rat eats about 10% of its
body weight a day and still this lesser
Bandicoot rat ma manages to keep a
month's worth of food for her babies in
the pantry that means one heck of a lot
of shopping trips mostly at night but
nature does have some checks and
balances in place baby rats straying
from the safety of the nest make
tempting meals for several predators a
[Music]
barn owl captures a baby and the other
babies don't even seem to notice a
hungry sand boa ignores what's on the
surface and goes for the mother lode
into the rat burrow
[Music]
the rats have the good sense to get the
heck out of there it may seem like
they're safe but in fact they're under
estimating the craftiness of this
predator
[Music]
the San boa lives up to its name by
burying itself in sand perfectly
camouflaging itself from the returning
rats boa one rat nothing
but well don't feel too bad for the rats
there are billions of them lining up for
a rematch